we now have a lot of experience finding
the areas under curves when we're
dealing with things in rectangular
coordinates so we saw we took the
riemann sums a bunch of rectangles we
took the limits we had an infinite
number of infinitely thin rectangles and
we were able to find the area
but now let's move on to polar
coordinates and polar coordinates i
won't say we're finding the area under a
curve but really in this example right
over here we have a part of the graph of
r is equal to f of theta and we've
graphed it between theta is equal to
alpha and theta is equal to beta what i
want to do in this video is come up with
a general expression for this area in
blue
this area that is bounded i guess you
could say by those angles and the graph
of r
is equal to
r is equal to
f of theta
and i want you to come up or at least
attempt to come up with an expression on
your own but i'll give you a little bit
of a hint here when we did in
rectangular coordinates we divided
things into rectangles
over here rectangles don't seem as
obvious because they're all kind of
coming to this point
but what if we could divide things into
if we could divide things into
sector i guess we could say
little pie pieces
someone's doing some serious drilling
downstairs i don't know if it's picking
up on the microphone but anyway i will
continue
so what would happen if we could divide
this
into a whole series of
kind of
pie pieces
if we could divide into a whole series
of pie pieces
and then take the limit as if we had an
infinite number at the infinite number
of pie pieces so we're we want to find
the area of each of these pi pieces and
then take the limit as the pi pieces i
guess you could say become
infinitely thin and we have an infinite
and we have an infinite
number of them and i'll give you one
more hint i'll give you one more hint
for thinking about the area of these pie
i guess you could say pie the area of
these pie wedges i'll give you another
hint
so if i have a circle under my best
attempt at a circle
luckily the
the plumbing or whatever is going on
downstairs has stopped for now allowing
me to focus more on the calculus which
is obviously more important
all right so if i have a circle that's
my best attempted circle and it's of
radius r
it's of radius r and let's say let me
draw a sector of this circle
it's a sector of a circle so that's
obviously r as well
and if this angle right here is theta
what is going to be the area
what is going to be the area of this
sector
right over here so that's my hint for
you think about what this area is going
to be and we're assuming theta is in
radians think about what this area is
going to be and then see if you can
extend that to what we're trying to do
here to figure out a
somehow i'm i'm giving you a hint again
using integration
finding an expression for this area
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it so
first let's think about this so what's
the area of the entire the area of the
entire circle well we already know that
that's going to be pi r squared
formula for the area of a circle
and then what's going to be the area of
this what's going to be a fraction of
the circle
if this is pi
sorry if this is theta where they if we
went 2 pi radians that would be the
whole circle so this is going to be pi
this is going to be theta over 2 pi of
the circle
so times theta over
over
2 pi
times theta over
2 pi would be the area of this sector
right over here area of the whole circle
times the proportion of the circle that
we've kind of we have defined or that
the sector is made up of and so this
would give us this would give us the
pi's cancel out it would give us one
half
r squared times theta
now
what happens if instead of theta
so let's let's look at each of these
over here
so each of these things that i've drawn
so let's focus just on one of these one
of these wedges
i will highlight it in
orange
i'll highlight it in orange
so
instead of the angle being theta let's
just assume it's a really really really
small angle let's we'll use a
differential this is a little bit of
loosey-goosey mathematics but the
important here is to give you the
conceptual understanding i could call it
a
delta theta and then to eventually take
the limit as our delta theta approach
zero but i'm just gonna just for
conceptual purposes assuming we have a
infinitely small or super small
change in theta so let's call that
d
theta
and
d theta and this
this the the radius here
or i guess we could say this length
right over here you could view it as the
radius of at least the arc
right at that point it's going to be r
it's going to be r as a function of the
thetas that we're around right over here
but we're just going to call that our r
right over there and so what is going to
be the area of this little sector
well the area of this little sector
is going instead of my angle being theta
i'm calling my angle d theta this little
differential so instead of one half r
squared it's going to be let me do that
in a color you can see this
this
is this area is going to be one half
r squared
d
theta notice here the angle was theta
here the angle is just d theta super
super small angle
now if i wanted to take the sum of all
of these from theta is equal to alpha to
theta is equal to beta and really
there's an infinite number of these this
is an infinitely small angle well then
for the entire
for the entire area right over here
i could just integrate i could just
integrate all of these so that's going
to be
the integral
from
alpha
to
beta
of
one half r squared
one half
r squared
d theta where r of course is a function
of theta so you could even write it this
way you could write it as the integral
from alpha to beta of one half
r
of theta
squared d theta just to remind ourselves
we're assuming r is a function of theta
in this case